carlotta für mich ist er schon lange der
minister der ausgrenzung und er hat
wieder einmal bewiesen dass er es
bleiben will erinnern wir uns einmal
zurück an eine zeit die für viele ganz
schlimm war zweig im winter diese
fürchterliche spaltung die wir erlebt
haben wir haben menschen in gruppen
einsortiert du bist geimpft du bist
nicht geimpft du bist solidarisch weil
du bist du bist nicht solidarisch weil
du nicht geimpft wird die zeit war
fürchterlich und sie war falsch wir
haben ja auch schon gestern der runde
gehabt die gesagt haben ich habe nur
gedacht ich habe nachgedacht und mir tut
es auch leid was letzten winter passiert
ist aber einer der sieht das nicht so
das ist unser gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der unterscheidet immer noch
auch jetzt zwischen den guten geimpften
und den bösen die sich gegen die impfung
entschieden haben und hat sich erst
gestern über demonstranten echauffiert
und ich möchte ihnen das gerne hier
einmal zeigen
runterspielen habe dazu keinen beitrag
geleistet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das noch geht stellen haben wie wichtig
uns dazu zu missbrauchen
gegen arbeitet haben diese kinder gut
wie möglich belastet sind
frau schimpft wenn sie das jetzt sehen
als politikerin darf ein minister sagen
sie sind berechtigt zu demonstrieren sie
nicht sie haben keinen beitrag geleistet
ist es nicht ihr recht das heißt
menschen die gegen die impfung sind oder
die vielleicht probleme damit haben
haben keine berechtigung da zu sein hat
ja eigentlich gesagt natürlich darf man
das nicht und ich habe diese zeit gerade
auch den letzten winter und das früher
wirklich als große belastung erleben
müssen sowohl als politikerin als auch
als mensch sie müssen sich vorstellen
bei mir sitzen völlig verängstigte
menschen auf dem sofa im bürgerbüro des
sind pflegerinnen und pfleger es sind
leute die im gesundheitswesen tätig sind
es sind sogar leute die inzwischen im
ausland tätig sind weil sie es nicht
mehr aushalten und weil sie damit
schlichtweg nicht zurecht kommen und ich
habe schon vor einiger zeit gesagt wann
wer befreit diesen man eigentlich von
seinem amt für mich ist das eine
absolute fehlbesetzung
der kann gerne in professor ahlen runden
auftreten und dort seine thesen
verkünden aber er ist niemand den dieses
land versteht und den selbst ich nicht
verstehe und deswegen wird es zeit für
einen wechsel herr kessler wann befreien
wir diesen mann von seinem amt
mehrfacher befreien wir wird in
deutschland von ihm befreien und ihm von
diesem amt genau und er wird würden in
der hinterbank zurückerstatten von der
er gekommen ist dass wir auch schon für
die hinterbank also win win win die
frage ist natürlich wer ist die größere
lücke im kabinett muss man etwas groß zu
sagen da haben wir ja jeden tag neue
kandidaten frau lamprecht ist ein
dauerkandidaten mit ist von praktisch
von null auf zwei ist die
staatsministerin roth gerückt geschossen
sozusagen durch schlechtes verhalten
beim antisemitismus skandal der
dokumente was hier natürlich das ganz
schlimme ist er desavouiert leute
demonstrieren das ist grundgesetzlich
verbürgte das gegen einen feuchten
kehricht an und er unterstellt leuten
die mutmaßlich gegen die impfpflicht
demonstrieren sie seien generell gegen
die impfung und wir gegen die impfung
sei
aber kein recht sich öffentlich zu
äußern weil er kein beitrag geleistet
habe da kann ich nur sagen abgerechnet
wird am schluss vielleicht haben auch
ungeimpfte pfleger menschen sehr sehr
viel gutes getan genauso gut wie
geimpfte pfleger man kann doch jetzt
nicht sagen nachdem wir hoffentlich
hoffentlich diese spaltung etwas
überwunden hatten 2g 3g 0 g 5 g was was
ich noch immer kommt der lauterbach und
sagt na ja es gibt nicht nur die
kämpften ungeimpften es gibt auch die
rechtmäßig demonstrierenden und die
unrechtmäßig demonstrieren er maßt sich
an er macht sich kompetenz an dir nicht
hat das ist leiter der rote faden und
ich muss sagen gäbe es nicht noch
schwächere war ja schon weg aus dem
kabinett verriet wenn sie das sehen
denken sie gut dass ich deutschland
verlassen habe ich sehe ja
ich hab mir du kannst du hingucken dafür
ist natürlich möchte ich wissen was in
deutschland los ist und dann werden laut
aber auch sehr das ist
gänsehaut weil es sieht auch nicht
gesund aus der mann gibt auch nicht viel
gesundes von sich ich halte von ihm
wirklich nichts war ein fehler und ich
denke da sollte man mal was macht man
muss wirklich sagen ich habe noch nie
ein so gespaltenes land erlebt wie in
den letzten zwei jahren und die
gespräche am familientisch oder im
freundeskreis drehten sich immer um die
frage bist du schon geimpft oder bist du
es nicht und sie haben sich am ende in
diese beiden richtungen gespalten das
ist furchtbar für ältere menschen
zerbrachen freundeskreise
senioren haben sich nicht mehr getraut
ihre kinder oder enkelkinder zu sehen
was ist das für ein zustand man konnte
nicht mehr im beisein seiner angehörigen
dieses leben für diese welt verlassen
das ist das ist ich finde dafür keine
worte dann darf sich nie wieder und
dafür 1 erst noch zu laut aber wenn wir
uns hier vielleicht sogar eigentlich
sein sollten dass er wirklich ein
verdammt schlechten job macht also
maximal ungeeignet ist das ein mehr
probleme mit sicherheit als mit dem amt
oder noch genauso viele probleme darf
man auch nicht vergessen es gab bis vor
kurzem wieder umfragen wo er nach wie
vor als einer der beliebten minister
galt er ist ja letzten endes nur auf
diesen sessel gekommen weil er das
beliebte torfrau eigentlich entscheid
eigentlich an die medien und die
pressevertreter ihnen zum minister
faschist der so sehr interesse ist oder
aber er ist nach wie vor glaube ich
nicht bei allen so durch wie es jetzt
vielleicht erscheinen ich glaube das
problem ist wegen angeblicher es um eins
ist natürlich ich verstehe dass sie
gesagt haben dass emotionale und es war
eine schwere zeit mir macht mir sorge
was kommt demnächst weil
das grundproblem es schwer haben ist wir
wissen gar nicht was wirkt ja wärmer der
politik die seit über zwei jahren bruder
maßnahme greift ohne zu wissen ob die
wirklich wirken also wir haben sind land
glaube ich mit den längsten
schulschließungen die schweizer drei
wochen die schule geschlossen wir haben
großbritannien wurde man sich diesen so
schlimm aber wenn man ehrlich sind die
war eine erste welle hatten die viel
mehr tote als wir da hatten wir einfach
die schweden hatten wir nicht da waren
wenig besser als großbritannien und ich
habe mir viel lockerer politik hier sind
im blindflug und wenn heute die
gesundheitsminister tagen und wieder
sagen wir müssten radikalere und
einschränkungen vor plan von herbst es
fehlt einfach die datenbasis und das ist
das was ich eine erschreckend finde das
eben wir als ein führender
industrienationen
fragen auf der ganzen auf der ganzen
linie versagt habe ich habe meine
anderen sind nur ein staatsversagen
gesprochen da wo ich hätte dich für
gescholtenen hunt ich bin aber der
auffassung was wir erlebt haben in
corona ist extra instanz ist
staatsversagen
und dass der lauterbacher zufällig quasi
da noch das gesicht hinhält fein und du
bist in der tat falsche aussagen und
dann ihre ausnahme ist schlimm genug
aber es ist nicht das kern des problems
kernproblem ist viel größer ist nicht
nur lauter braucht also egal was morgen
kommt auch der hat keine daten auf ihr
agieren aber er ist schon ein ganz
besonderes problem ich möchte jetzt doch
nicht so schnell am haken lassen hier es
war ja nicht gerade die bundespräsident
die pressekonferenz nach der konferenz
der gesundheitsminister und er hatte es
innerhalb von 30 minuten von 30 minuten
fundamental widersprochen er sagt erst
erwartet eine schwere corona welle einen
schweren herbst eine schwere zeit wurde
daten und das heißt wie auch immer und
30 minuten später sagt er dann ja er
geht davon aus die neue virusvariante
sei nur mittelschwer das heißt also ein
mittelschwerer virus löst eine sehr
schwere bälle aus dann wird er kommt
drauf angesprochen das geht ihm alles
durchgesagt in zehn minuten was anderes
als vor 20 minuten und das ist einfach
in grenzen